I'm standing for Parliament at the next
election and I wonder if she'd give me a
few minutes to talk to you I've got a
leaflet here and you'll fight your see
I've written down ways to reduce the
deficit thank you what I'd like to do
let's get my generation to be more
proactive you can't get much more
actively involved than standing for
Parliament can you expect will you bear
not decided yet so how much of the kind
of walking around and door knocking you
are you going to be able to do you do
not a lot I'm giving talks 30,000
leaflets delivered to everybody I've got
my blog and I'm hoping that the word
will get around and that people will
agree with what I'm saying do you think
that'll be enough though because of
course you're going up against the big
parties aren't you who knows i get the
biscuits out i will be 85 in march so i
will be 85 by the time i stand as a
candidate people will say oh she's too
old and she'll drop dead anyway but um
it can be an enormous advantage because
I have experience I went through the war
but I've survived everything and I
didn't need any what is it they have to
go for counseling I will do whatever is
necessary to get elected do you think
you will be elected that's in the lap of
the gods isn't it